FRANCIS MA: [INAUDIBLE].
Good afternoon.
How's everybody doing
here today?
AUDIENCE: Good.
FRANCIS MA: Excellent.
You guys enjoying your Pixels,
the Chromebook?
You've had time to play
around with it?
Excellent.
So my name is Francis,
Francis Ma.
I'm one of the product managers
on the Google+
platform team.
CHRIS CARTLAND: My name's
Chris Cartland.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ platform.
FRANCIS MA: And today, we're
going to be talking about
cross-platform auth with
Google+ Sign-In.
So just before we start,
I just want to
gauge the crowd here.
How many of you guys have
a cross-platform app?
For example, you build
on Android and web,
maybe iOS and web both.
All right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Mostly hands.
FRANCIS MA: There's a good
number of you, yeah.
Excellent.
So today, we're going to
be talking about--
first, we're going to cover
auth, give you an overview of
Google+ Sign-In.
We're going to talk about how
this relates to your server
and where auth comes in.
We're going to go through the
various auth models of how you
integrate this on the client
side, on the server side.
And then lastly, we're going
to be taking questions.
And for the audience who are
watching on our live stream,
we have a Q&A set up so that you
can also submit questions.
And we also have the link at
the bottom of the slides so
you guys can have the
URL as we go along.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So let's start
talking about auth.
I've been working a lot with
different applications to help
integrate Google+ Sign-In.
And I've realized that people
spend a lot of time talking
about auth.
And that's because it's really
important to get right.
And in the next half hour, we're
going to try and make
sure we can save you a lot of
time by explaining how to do
auth correctly in your
cross-platform applications
with Google+.
So the first thing is that auth
is really talking about
two different things.
One of them is authentication.
And that's knowing
who a user is.
The second one is
authorization.
And that's actually having
permission to do something.
And in our case, it means having
something to do with
Google, permission
to do something.
So an example is I
have a California
identification in my pocket.
And if I showed that to anyone,
that would be pretty
convincing to say that
I am Chris Cartland.
However, if I showed up at
Moscone Center and tried to
get in today to Google I/O, they
wouldn't let me in just
with my identification.
Because that doesn't
prove that I'm
authorized to be here.
And what I need instead is to
have my Google I/O badge.
And that is my authorization.
It says that I have permission
to do something with Google.
And so there's a difference
between the two of them.
And it's good to know that
when you're talking about
authentication, which is knowing
who a user is, and
authorization, which is having
access to do something.
FRANCIS MA: So building your own
auth is really difficult.
And that's something that we
don't recommend you do.
You have to worry about things
like how you transport this--
if [? users ?] to send your
password, are you sending it
over an encrypted tunnel?
How do you store it?
Do you salt it, hash it?
And also, sometimes maybe
just having one
password is not enough.
And you've got to worry
about 2-factor auth.
And then lastly, a lot
of times, users
forget their passwords.
And I do that all the time.
And it is something that you
definitely don't want to have
to deal with in terms
of providing
the customer support.
So we encourage you not to
build your own auth.
And oftentimes, when you don't
get this right, a lot of bad
things can happen.
For example, this is
not how you want to
make headline news.
So whenever you're thinking
about implementing your own
auth, think about the
difficulties that you may
potentially have run into
and the ramifications
of getting it wrong.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Fortunately,
you can
use an identity provider.
You want to do this because
it's easier for you.
You don't have to do all the
hard things that Francis just
talked about.
It's also easier for your user
because they don't have to
remember more passwords.
So additionally, when you use
an identity provider you can
often use features of those
specific platforms in order to
make your app better.
And we think this is a better
way to reach your goal.
So we really recommend not to
build your own authentication
and to use someone else
to do it for you.
FRANCIS MA: So one such
provider is Google.
A couple months ago, we launched
Google+ Sign-In.
And with that, we handle
auth for you.
Now, in addition to taking the
burdens off your hand, we have
hundreds of millions
of users across
all of Google services--
things like Gmail, YouTube,
Android, and such--
so that as an authentication
provider, your users don't
have to create a new
account and you can
delegate that to us.
Secondly, we make it easy by
providing a lot of client
libraries and SDKs so that you
don't have to worry about the
nitty-gritties.
And we handle a lot
of that for you.
And lastly is by integrating
Google+ Sign-In, you also
unlock the benefits of the
Google+ platform, from things
like helping you drive
distribution, if you are an
Android developer with our
over-the-air install feature;
driving user engagement through
interactive posts; and
writing app activities
to Google.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So everything
with Google+ Sign-In is based
on OAuth 2.0.
And so this is a protocol that
allows a user to give some
access to their account with
Google without giving you
everything.
So there's no password
sharing.
There's scoped access.
So you not only don't have to
share a password, but you
don't have to give up your
entire life to an app just to
let them do something.
And this access is revocable.
So it's a good security model in
case access does get in the
wrong hands.
In order to set up OAuth, you
need to start with the Google
API console.
And this is where you
set up a project.
A project is the place where
all of your app starts.
So you have your branding
information there, which is
your name and a photo, so that
a user knows who they're
authorizing.
And within this one project, you
may have multiple clients.
And that means you have
an Android app, an iOS
app, and a web app.
And with each of those, you need
to give Google a little
bit of information so we know
where your app lives.
So on Android and iOS and web,
you provide a little piece of
information.
And that all exists in one
project that a user is going
to authorize.
FRANCIS MA: So one of the key
things we definitely want you
to take away with is that
setting up this project is
very important.
Having the right structure with
the top-level project and
your clients underneath that
tells us this is your service.
And relating to auth, this is
important because when a user
signs in with Google and grants
consent to your app,
you're granting consent to
your service, not just a
specific client--
not just to your Android app,
to your web app, or whatnot.
It's about the whole thing.
And yesterday, in the Android
keynote, Hugo announced the
cross-platform single sign-on,
the notion that when a user
signs in on the web, they get
automatically signed in on
Android as well.
So this is very important
to set up correctly.
Keep that in mind.
So now let's look at where
auth comes in to your
architecture.
Now, many of you are probably
familiar with this, where you
have a client server
and Google.
With auth, you need to think
about all three of these
lines, whether it's
from connecting
your client to Google--
how do we know this is
really your client--
from having your server
connected to Google, and also
between your client and
your own server.
So let's start by looking
at client-side auth.
So to do client auth, it's
really about how you connect
your client with Google
and making direct
API calls from there.
We're going to be walking
through how you do that over
Android, iOS, and web.
So starting with Android--
on Android, we have Google Play
services, which is an
extension of the Google Play
platform on Android for you to
integrate with Google
services.
With that, we've embedded all
the logic you need to handle
auth so that you don't have
to worry about it.
For you as a developer, all you
need is to integrate the
client library, and we will deal
with the auth from there.
And the good news about Google
Play services API is that it's
available from Android
2.2 and up.
So that for you as a developer,
you can have
confidence that this API is
going to be there in a
consistent manner, no matter
what version of Android the
user is using.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So let's
get started.
Basically what we're trying to
do is get the user into a
state where they
are connected.
We'll come back to this diagram
in a moment, so don't
worry too much about it.
First of all, everything fits
into what would typically be
like an activity lifecycle.
onCreate--
you need to create
the PlusClient.
This is the object that
interacts with Google Play
services and does all of
the hard work for you.
onStart--
you need to ask it to connect.
And of course, onStop--
you need it to disconnect, to
clean up the connection.
And in the middle, while the
app is running, a user may
need to click a sign-in button
in order to get started.
We provide a button for you
in this button layout.
And what's really nice is that
this is localized into the
user's preferred speaking
language.
So you don't have
to do that work.
When your app tries to connect,
one of two things is
going to happen.
Either it's going to succeed,
and we call onConnected.
And in that case, you're done.
And you can already know
who the user is.
It's very easy.
The other option is that
it's going to fail.
And that happens for a
number of reasons.
Either the user hasn't chosen
an account yet.
Maybe the user hasn't authorized
your app yet.
And there can be many states in
there where a user hasn't
quite fully authorized your
app and signed in.
And so we just store that
failure because that means the
user is not quite ready
to work with you yet.
Now, when a user clicks the
sign-in button, that's when
you try and actually
complete the steps
necessary to sign in.
You make sure that they clicked
the sign-in button,
that we haven't already signed
in, and that we have a
connection result.
So this connection result was
that object be stored.
And it contains an intent that
does everything that's
necessary to get the
user signed in.
You don't even have to worry
about what all those details
are because Google Play
services handles
all of that for you.
The only thing you have to
do is ask Google Play
services to do it.
So we say mConnectionResult dot
startResolutionForResult.
The user may go through a bunch
of steps through Google
Play services.
But once they've done whatever
they need to do,
onActivityResult
will be called.
And from there, you just have to
call Connect again with the
PlusClient.
And we expect this to trigger
the onConnected callback.
So looking at this diagram
again, we start on onStart.
And one of two things will
happen when we call Connect.
Either we'll be connected and
finish, or it will fail.
When we fail, that means we
store the connection result.
And when the user clicks the
sign-in button, we try and
resolve it.
And there is a chance that
onActivityResult will go back
to the failed state.
And that's because the user
could have disconnected the
app, or they could've changed
accounts on their device.
But that's OK, because your
code already handles the
resolution for that.
And Google Play services is set
up to make sure that this
is as easy as possible.
FRANCIS MA: So we just
looked at how you
can do that on Android.
We also have that for
iOS, as well.
Now, iOS is a little bit
different, where we handle all
the auth logic for you in
the form of an SDK.
So for you as a developer, you
can get our Google+ iOS SDK
and integrate that
with your app.
And we, again, handle
the auth for you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So on
iOS, we need to set
up the sign-in object.
So we set your client ID, which
is how Google knows
which app you are.
You can also specify
your scopes.
And we say that we're going to
fetch the Google user ID.
This is the fastest way for
us to actually just know
who the user is.
We set the sign-in delegate to
whatever's going to implement
the GPPSignInDelegate
protocol.
And that means that it will
call the object when it's
completed the auth.
The sign-in button's
really easy in iOS.
You actually don't have
to write any code.
You just have to add a button
to your view, change the
custom class to GPPSignIn.
And then the SDK takes care of
the rest, which also localizes
the sign-in button to the
user's local language.
You can always use
your own button.
And if you do that, you should
follow our branding
guidelines, which we have
in our documentation.
And then you need to explicitly
call GPPSignIn
sharedInstance authenticate.
And that's because if you've
made your own button, the iOS
SDK that Google provides cannot
handle it without you.
So once you call that, though,
you will sign in the user,
which takes the user to Google
to complete the authorization
and authentication steps.
When that's done, Google will
open your app with a URL with
a custom scheme.
And you need to handle
that URL.
So this is where you typically
handle incoming URLs.
And what we provide for
you is GPPURLHandler.
And this is great because
it looks at the URL.
It first figures out,
was this coming in
from a signed-in user?
If it is, it will return,
yes, it is.
And it will also call
Finished with Auth.
And it will give you all
the authentication
information you need.
It'll store everything
in the SDK.
And you'll be ready to go.
From there, you can just call
GPPSignIn sharedInstance to
get information like
the user ID.
FRANCIS MA: So we've covered
Android and iOS.
For web, it's even easier.
All you need to do is include
our JavaScript client onto
your page and add the Google+
Sign-In button.
And we'll handle the user auth
with a click of a button.
And for you, you just have to
handle the auth callback.
So let's take a look
at how this works.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So really easy--
we provide a sign-in
button for you.
Again, you put your client
ID in there so we
know who you are.
Then you just need to include
plusone.js, which is the
JavaScript that is the common
JavaScript that you'll use for
the +1 button or for
other widgets.
When the user has
authenticated,
you will get a callback.
And in that callback, you
will get an auth result.
If the auth result has an access
token, which is a sign
that they have information
that gives you access to
Google, then you know that
they're authorized.
And you can immediately start
making API calls.
You actually don't even need
to look at the access token
other than just to make sure
it's there, because the
JavaScript library already uses
the tokens as necessary
in order to make API calls.
FRANCIS MA: So we've talked
about client-side auth.
Now let's take a look
at how you do this
on the server side.
So with server auth, it's about
connecting the server
with Google.
Now when you have multiple
clients, oftentimes you would
have back-end servers so you can
put a lot of your business
logic in there so you don't have
to replicate it across
your clients.
Now, doing that--
the good side is you don't
have to replicate it.
But it is a little bit trickier
when it comes to
auth, because now you have to
authenticate your client and
server and then now also
authenticate server with Google.
So let's take a look
at how we do that.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Let's
start with iOS.
In this one, we're going to just
send the access token to
your server.
So this is the piece of
information that we need to
get from the client, which has
already done all the steps
we've talked about earlier.
And we need to get that
information to your server.
So make sure that you send
these tokens securely.
And that's because they
are bearer tokens.
Anyone who has them has
information about the user and
can act on behalf in any
way that your app is
authorized to do so.
So make sure that you
don't lose those.
Send them securely.
Also, keep in mind that
these access tokens
only last one hour.
And they will expire.
So design your app
accordingly.
On Android, you can
do the same thing.
You can get the access token
from GoogleAuthUtil.
Again, send it securely.
Make sure that your server
cannot [INAUDIBLE] these in
order to protect your users.
Once you have sent this token
to your server, you need to
verify that access token.
There's two things
you need to know.
First, did this token
come from Google?
If it didn't, then you
shouldn't be doing
anything with it.
Second is to make sure that
it is issued to you.
The reason this is important
is if someone else were to
send a Google access token for
their app to your server, they
could sign in users to your
app without a user ever
actually using your app.
So you need to make sure that
you've checked that the client
ID that you've set up in the API
console matches what you
get from this token.
And all this comes from the
token info endpoint, which you
can see here.
So that was sending
access tokens.
Additionally, we have this
one-time code that you can
send to your server.
So it's very similar code.
It's just a string.
And you also want to send
that to your server.
There's advantages here.
The code can only be used
by your server.
It is not a bearer token.
This code can also get
an access token
and a refresh token.
Access tokens last one hour.
Refresh tokens don't expire.
So using this one-time code that
you send to your server,
it's both more secure--
because even if that code was
intercepted, it's useless to
anybody except for you.
And then secondly, you can get
a refresh token, which means
your server can have access even
when the user is offline.
On the web, we really recommend
sending the code.
So you get the string from
the auth result--
really easy.
Send that to your server.
You get all the benefits of
security as well as having the
refresh token to
make API calls.
When you get this code on your
server, you again need to do
something with it.
In this case, you just
exchange that code.
Exchanging that code will give
you an access token.
And if you ask for offline
access, you will also get a
refresh token.
This is really easy because our
client libraries take care
of this for you.
Like in Ruby--
authorization.fe
tch_access_token.
Credentials, you just
exchange code.
Client, authenticate
with a code.
So these are all just
one line, very easy.
And our library will take care
of the exchange for you.
And from there, you also again
don't have to worry about
dealing with the access token
or refresh token.
Because the library
does that for you.
This is fully available
in our Quick Starts.
You can pick your language and
have it running in 10 minutes.
It's really easy.
So looking at ways to enable
server-side auth--
depending on which platform
you have, you can
do different things.
So all of them have
an access token.
You can always just send that
string from your client to
your server.
You need to make sure you do it
securely because you really
don't want anybody to
intercept those.
But once you do that, then
you know who they are.
And you'll be able to use that
token to make API requests.
The better thing, if you can do
it, is to use the one-time
code exchange.
And that is not available
on iOS.
Just this week, we are launching
it on Android.
So you can get that code and
send it to your server.
And of course, you
can do it on web.
And of course, the code is more
secure, and you can get
the refresh token.
FRANCIS MA: So now that you've
looked at how you integrate
auth across multiple platforms,
another thing to
think about is oftentimes,
you're doing this because you
already have an existing
auth system.
And there are more things to
think about in that scenario
for things like how do you
merge the user accounts.
For example, if you already
have your own login and
password, when a user comes in
and signs in with Google
instead, you probably don't
want to create a brand-new
user account.
And instead, you would want to
take that and merge it so that
they're not starting
from scratch.
Now, our colleague Ian had
given a talk about this
earlier in the day.
And his session will be
available through YouTube and
the archive as well.
So be sure to check that out
if that applies for you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So what
did we just cover?
We actually covered a lot.
So we covered that you don't
want to build your own
authentication system.
That should be obvious,
especially if you went to Tim
Bray's talk.
Google+ makes authentication
easy.
We've actually just shown you
how to do it on Android, how
to do it on iOS, how to do it
on the web, and how to get
information from each of
those to your server.
We have code that shows you how
to deal with this on your
server in five languages.
You can take those and just use
it and run it immediately.
All this is available in our
Quick Starts, which will take
you 10 minutes to run.
If you want to see a larger
application that kind of puts
all the pieces together--
it runs on Android, it runs on
iOS, and it runs on the web--
you can take a look at
PhotoHunt, which is our big
application that shows you kind
of how everything will
fit together.
This is available on
our website at
developers.google.com/+.
And we also have additional
code available on
github.com/googleplus.
And this will do things like--
there's a bunch of samples
that we just released today
that will show you how to
verify the tokens that
you send from
your app to your server.
So really, no matter which
platform you're coming from,
you'll be able to bring
authentication and
authorization all together in
one place and really make your
application run everywhere that
your users want to be.
FRANCIS MA: All right.
Thanks for coming out.
And we can take questions,
live questions here.
And we'll also go on the live
Q&A on the internet.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Should I
go first, then?
FRANCIS MA: All right.
We have somebody here.
AUDIENCE: So I just want to
make sure I understand the
one-time token.
So if my application--
like say, if my Android
application--
it requests--
actually, let's start
with JavaScript.
So do I need to change anything
in my JavaScript to
indicate that I want a one-time
token that I'm going
to exchange on my server
as opposed to a
regular access token?
And my second part of the
question is, if I do then
exchange that token, my
server has the token.
Do I need to then do something
application-specific on my
server that passes back into,
say, my Android application,
that then says, this is how I'm
authenticating between my
server and my client,
essentially?
Does that make sense
what I'm asking?
Because I see that the server
then has a secure token that
is only stored on the server.
I'm not passing that
back and forth.
But my client--
if I disconnect, shut down the
app, and then come back, if
I'm jumping back into the
server, the server needs to
say, who are you?
And I'm not asking them
to authenticate
again at that point.
Am I?
Or can I trust--
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so let's
start with the first one,
because I can answer
that quickly.
For JavaScript, the code
is just there.
You have to ask for offline
access, which is a parameter
in the button.
And then the code will
be valid for
getting a refresh token.
The code is there even if you
don't ask for offline access.
But it will just get you an
access token in that case.
Sorry.
So onto the second part
of your question.
Can you try that
one more time?
AUDIENCE: So let's say my
application, then, goes
through the normal G+ sign-in.
I request a token.
I then go to send it to the
server, one-time token.
The server exchanges it.
And I've got an access
token on the server.
My app, then--
how does my server know that
it can trust the app?
Because that one-time token
has expired, right?
So I can't send that back
through and test it at Google
and say, this is a valid?
So my client disconnects.
Do I just trust that the client
has authenticated and
it's compiled Java code?
CHRIS CARTLAND: So in that
connection where that code was
sent, if you have a session of
some sort and you can know
that that channel is the same
session, then once you've
exchanged that code and it was
valid, you can trust all the
information that was returned
from Google.
Additionally, you know that that
session came from an app
that was your app.
Because that code won't work
unless it actually came from
one of the clients that
Google set up.
AUDIENCE: So it is sort of
application-specific?
Every server-side library
will generate a
session token for me.
But that's happening in my app
that I need to then manage.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So you have to
manage your own session there.
If you don't have any sort of
sessions at all, and you need
to send authentication
information with every
request, what you can do
is use the ID token.
We didn't actually cover
that in this talk.
But one of the pieces of data
that you can get back on
Android and the web
is an ID token.
This can be sent along
with each request.
And it can be very quickly
verified to know that it was
from Google and that the
information contained within
it is valid.
And that will give
you the user ID.
So the advantage of that is that
if you don't need to get
the authorization information to
Google and you just need to
authenticate that request
to your back
end, you can offline--
or if you have the assigned Java
web token that allows you
to verify that it's real and
signed by Google and that it's
for your app.
You can take a look on
GitHub for how to
validate the ID token.
We have samples in all five
of our back end languages.
AUDIENCE: So to clarify then--
so on my server, I would key
in my database that I've got
this user ID in Google.
And then from the client,
I send that token in.
I validate it.
And I come back and say,
this is the ID.
And then I look up and say,
OK, now I've got this auth
token and I can use
it effectively.
That's basically--
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yup,
that's right.
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, thanks
for the question.
FRANCIS MA: Another thing
to know, just to
elaborate on that--
one of our developer advocates,
Tim Bray, wrote an
extensive article.
It's called "How to Authenticate
Your Client with
your Home Server." And this
is on the Android blog.
And that also covers very
much in depth on
what you just asked.
CHRIS CARTLAND: I think
it's a blog post--
"Verifying Back-End
Calls on Android."
Something like that--
I always get the name wrong.
Let me look at one of the
questions on here.
It says, "Can my application ask
the user's authorization
to post or create a new item
in their Google+ stream?"
So right now, our API, our REST
API, where you can just
make post requests to it, does
not support writing directly
to the stream.
You can look at more at Google
Sign-In features, like app
activity, which is a way
that you can actually
write data to Google.
Yeah, a live question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My question is, does the iOS
SDK integrate with existing
Google+ app?
Or is it like a web interface?
Like for example, if you already
have the Google+ app
like Facebook does
for [? use. ?]
Switch to the Facebook app.
It goes through the
OAuth token.
And then you switch back to
your own application.
FRANCIS MA: So with the iOS SDK,
if the user already has
the Google+ app installed, we
will fast switch over to the
Google+ app so that the user
doesn't have to retype their
login and password.
We use the logged-in user's
identity of the Google+ app.
And then we just do the OAuth
connection there.
But if the user doesn't have
the Google+ app installed,
then we go to the browser.
AUDIENCE: And is there any
chance that in the future, it
will be integrated like a
Facebook or Twitter use now,
or where they have like
a first-class
integration with the iOS?
Or you cannot comment on that?
FRANCIS MA: We don't have
anything to announce at this
time about that.
CHRIS CARTLAND: But
we'd always like
to make things better.
We realize that right now, the
signing in experience is
better on Android.
But we'd always like to improve
everything that we can.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Let's
see here.
"Is there a difference between
a Google Apps for Business
versus a Gmail user using
Google+ Sign-In a website/app?
And can my website/app see if
that user is a Google Apps for
Business user?"
So Google Apps for Business
works just fine with Google+
if the apps administrator
has Google+ turned on.
So right now, it doesn't
work if the
administrator turns that off.
Other than that, once it's on,
you actually can't tell the
difference between a user just
because they're a-- it's
Google+ user.
AUDIENCE: So does
that mean that--
because I'm curious
about this, too.
What if you are not a Google
Apps for Business?
What if you're just a normal
Google user that has not
turned on Google+?
Can you still login
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah,
so the ques--
FRANCIS MA: Sorry, go ahead.
To repeat the question
from the audience--
the question was, if the user is
not already a Google+ user,
can they use Google+ Sign-In?
Is that correct?
Yes, so the answer is, yes.
As part of the sign-in flow,
if the user is not yet a
Google+ user, we take them
through an upgrade flow where
they do get to upgrade
as a Google+ user.
And the process for that is
simply verifying their name so
they have a Google+ profile.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So we've written
the code that does
that for you, like in Google
Play services.
That takes you through
all the steps there.
And on the web, we
do a quick flow.
And then it takes you back.
Same idea.
Good question.
Did you have something else?
AUDIENCE: I have something about
this question, also.
If a user cannot create a
Google+ account-- for example,
if you do a game for the kids
and they cannot create Google+
accounts because of the
age constraints.
Is there a kind of fallback
scenario, that the user can
just use the credentials from
Gmail or something like this?
Because the identification
should work pretty much the
same way like Google+.
For the games, this will not
work, because the kids cannot
create Google+ account.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So you're asking
about accounts for
people who don't meet the age
requirements to use Google+?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So under 13 years old, you
cannot subscribe to Google+.
So it means that for kids'
games, you cannot use
this to sign in.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So Google+
Sign-In won't work for people
who cannot have a
Google+ account.
AUDIENCE: Is there some
libraries which can work with
just like Google authentication
without having
Google+ account?
Because authentication
mechanics are
pretty much the same.
OAuth is there and [INAUDIBLE]
is there.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So like I say,
yeah, Google+ Sign-In does not
work if a user can't have
a Google+ account.
So we're restricted by that.
FRANCIS MA: Part of the value
you get for integrating
Google+ Sign-In is that you
also get to tap into the
Google+ platform as well.
So I've mentioned earlier, for
getting things like getting
access to the user's social
graph, being able to post to
Google+ with interactive posts,
and also using features
like the over-the-air
app install.
So that's the value you get
for using Google+ Sign-In.
But that is very good point you
made, which is there is a
set of users who may not be able
to upgrade and create a
Google+ profile.
And in that case, they
will not be able to
sign in this way.
AUDIENCE: Don't you think this
will be interesting to have
like a limited set of API
which provides the
authentication features but
not just Google+ features,
which can be really beneficial
for the applications.
But that's really strict from
posting [INAUDIBLE]
[? plus ?] pages and
things like this.
CHRIS CARTLAND: We're always
looking to make sure we can
get more users to make
the system work.
Like I said, it doesn't work
for apps users that have
Google+ turned off.
So there are these classes
of users that we can't
quite use right now.
But we think that we have a good
product for the ones that
it does work for.
Because we can do things like
cross-platform single sign-on.
So like when you go to your
Android app, the onConnected
callback is called
immediately.
And those are things that
we can only do once
everyone's in Google+.
So we don't have everybody yet,
but we'd like to improve
these situations.
AUDIENCE: That's the
whole point.
So you can't have
single sign-on
without having Google+.
Because authentication is there,
your Gmail and all
other services.
So you don't [INAUDIBLE]
[? need ?] to have Google+
unless you really want to post
on a Google+ page.
So is there a way to split the
framework in two parts, like
authentication part
and Google+ part?
FRANCIS MA: Not at the moment
at this time, but that's a
really good feedback.
We'll take that back.
Thank you.
CHRIS CARTLAND: I'm going to
look at the question here.
If you have multiple auth
systems, like you're a Django
Auth user and Google+ Sign-In.
Can I merge that account?" So
dealing with multiple accounts
is something that Ian Barber's
talk talks about.
It's actually-- he says using
Google+ Sign-In with other
social sign--
I forgot the title now.
But that also deals with--
basically, you have different
ways of authenticating a
user and how you keep
all of those straight.
So yeah, that would be a
good place to start.
And I think he covered
that there.
But basically, the idea is that
you do have to find some
way that makes sense for the
user to merge different
identities.
And I don't know if you want
to add anything to that.
FRANCIS MA: No, I think
that covers it.
And the material will be posted
back on the Google I/O
site for you guys to
look at after.
So be sure to check that out.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Actually, the
gentleman before me answered
most of my questions but kind
of led to a new set of that.
My big excitement this year is
all the push for education,
like the next session
I'm going to.
But what I just realized by his
question and your answers
is that this whole Google+
authentication system is
completely worthless in that
sector for that very reason.
And I think maybe what he was
trying to ask and I'd like to
ask is, does this have any
tie-in with the existing
Google authentication system?
Like if I open up Chrome and
I'm logged in, I get that
little Sign-In As button.
Or is that available to do
something like what this is
doing for everyone that not
going to be old enough for G+?
FRANCIS MA: So I think
there are two
parts to your question.
The first one is, how do you
address the class of users who
are not able to participate
in G+?
And as we discussed, yeah, that
is something that we're
thinking about and to make
better over time.
Now, the second question,
which was, hey, is this
Google+ Sign-In built on
top of the existing
authentication system?
And the answer is yes, it is.
It is built on top of the
existing Google auth system.
We talked about using OAuth 2.0
and the standards there.
AUDIENCE: It's not
just OAuth 2.0.
And I can use that right now
for any Google user?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah,
that's right.
You can use that with
any Google user.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
FRANCIS MA: You're welcome.
CHRIS CARTLAND: All right.
Next one here says, "If a user
updates his info like his
email address on Google+, what
is the best practice to get
notified about such a change
to update this info in the
app?" So information to get
email is actually not part of
the Google+ API.
You can use a different OAuth
scope to get that.
And it works just as well.
You just add the userinfo.email
scope.
And then from there, you make a
request to Google to get the
email address.
So if any of the information
in our API has changed, we
don't actually have a
push system to tell
you what that is.
But you could call it again.
FRANCIS MA: And I think
generally, it is a good
practice to look at things
like your caching policy.
It is possible that users
do change their
information over time.
And so for your app, it's good
that you go back and check it
to make sure that you do have
the latest information.
CHRIS CARTLAND: One last
question here.
We're running out of time.
AUDIENCE: Actually, my question
is quite similar
with, it's a one-time code and
[INAUDIBLE] that he asked--
very similar.
So my question actually is,
for the iOS users, so that
means the server cannot support
the offline sharing
kind of things?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Correct.
Yeah, so from iOS, you
can't do that yet.
And we'd like to think of ways
to make this better, but it's
difficult right now.
AUDIENCE: So is there like
a schedule for when
we could have it?
CHRIS CARTLAND: So we have some
technical limitations.
Anyway, thanks for
your question.
So we're actually out of time.
But we'll be right out here
to answer any questions.
You feel free to come
by and talk to us.
But thank you so much.
And enjoy the rest of I/O.
FRANCIS MA: Thank you.